there does appear to be a lot of viral
research that has an overlap with
National Security uh Correctional
security apparatus I guess they call it
dual use
um How concerned you know should we be
in general about bioweapons at this
point
um you know is now the time
to start talking about it more now that
we have seen what a even an accidental
release or spillover or whatever the
case might be can do to the planet and
is there anything
that can be done about it
yes I think now is the time to be
concerned because this episode as as I
said earlier shown Bad actors what what
what could could be done and therefore
there must be some interest in
developing bioweapons in Terrorist
organizations and Rogue States
um uh clearly there is bio weapon
research going on in America in Britain
in China in Russia in other countries
but most of it is defensive
that is to say you know on the whole the
Chinese are concerned about a bioterror
incident
about someone unleashing a virus at the
Beijing Olympics for example and they
appointed the major general who's now in
charge of the wuhanistan virology to to
to develop
um surveillance techniques to try and
make sure that didn't happen during the
Beijing Olympics
um so uh you know the The Stance of
the U.S
certainly Britain and and ostensibly
China has been in recent years the
reason we do this kind of research is so
that we can defend against a bioterror
incident or possibly a bio Warfare
incident not because we want to use it
offensively ourselves
now
um where the you know at what point does
defense blur into offense is a good
question and uh are the labs where
secretly uh some of these countries
don't obey that
um guidance and do go further and say
let's see if we can use something that
we could stick in a weapon and throw at
our enemies and kill them before they uh
it has a chance to infect us and so on
um and that did used to go on in the
Cold War big time yeah no question that
you know Anthrax and others were being
weaponized for that use but uh this is
where the International Convention on
biological weapons I can't remember
quite what the acronym how it spells out
but that's roughly what it's called is a
very important
um treaty and it has very little teeth
it's not like the uh nuclear weapons
agreements at all and it really should
be looked at pretty urgently by the
United Nations and by
um uh the by world powers you know I
hope
that Anthony blinken is talking about
that with his counterpart in China when
they meet
how do how do you reckon we deal with
China at this point because you know
there you know one thing we didn't talk
about another piece of circumstantial
evidence that has come out recently is
we knew we've known for a while that
there were some researchers in the lab
that became ill in November of 2019
uh you know beginning of the pandemic uh
the the new information that's come to
light is that one of those researchers
was Ben who a scientist at the wuhanan's
virology who worked you know side by
side with she on these uh back
coronaviruses
um on how they infect humans and U.S
intelligence report I uh identifies his
him as one of the researchers who became
ill
um we have to you know qualify that and
say that American officials said they
were that the illness was consistent
with either covid-19 or other seasonal
illnesses it the what the illness was
has not been conclusively established
part of the reason for that is that
China's not relinquished any blood
samples for instance of their workers
that might have been taken at the
hospital and it's kind of part of the
general pattern uh especially early on
of China being this black box where you
can't get any good data out of there
they're shutting down the wet Market
they're shutting down research papers
that look at inconvenient questions
how do you deal with a regime like that
when you're trying to create some sort
of treaty to to get this Global danger
under control or under heal
yeah the the lack of transparency has
been truly shocking and and also
shocking was the World Health
Organization praising China for its
transparency during this lack of
transparency
um but uh you know not revealing the the
genetic database that they had in in the
lab not revealing what happened uh in
those early cases not talking about
those uh sick researchers
Etc now Ben who did come forward after
that Wall Street Journal article and uh
give an interview to science saying no
no I'm fine I was never never anything
wrong with me but we just can't trust
that kind of information these days
um Ben Who yuping and yanzhou the three
who allegedly got sick are all highly
relevant people they're all working in
exactly this area of SARS like
coronavirus research so if they did get
sick and we are told that they had
ground glass opacities in their lungs
which are pretty diagnostic feature
um uh then you know it it's it's of of
great relevance interestingly the reason
that came out those three names came out
a few weeks ago was because there was a
deadline for the U.S government under a
congressional act to release the
information that they held about what
happened in Wuhan and what happened to
the researchers in particular
and it was supposed to name the
researchers and give the details and
when the deadline passed the uh
Administration released only a brief
summary without the names without the
details and a week late
and
uh around that time
uh Michael schellenberger got the
information first Wall Street journaling
got it second
um there were Administration officials
who were prepared to release those names
seek privately to leak those names
um because they were frustrated
that the uh
um Administration was not going to obey
the Congressional directive and was not
going to include the names so it's clear
that the Biden administration at the
time remember Anthony blinkum was on his
way to Beijing at that very week it's
clear that the Biden Administration was
trying to bowdlerize
this obligation that they had in order
not to offend the Chinese government
we're in a very difficult situation in
the world where we are
trading and dealing with a an
organization we just can't trust anymore
that's a pretty serious position to have
found ourselves in
but it also leads to I mean a problem as
you're kind of talking about the United
States government is also and many of
its Chief actors are also the antithesis
of transparent at this point and have
given us many reasons not to trust them
in any given uh announcement
well exactly and as I hinted earlier a
lot of the reduction we're seeing when
they do respond to Freedom of
Information requests are driven by
political convenience and avoiding
embarrassment which is not supposed to
be a good reason for redacting uh
information yeah so can we talk a little
bit about
um the role of drastic uh the group as
well as open communication and Free
Speech you know both in this particular
instance where
you had governments of all different
types you know basically refusing to
come clean or to be open and transparent
with with its citizens and with the
scientific Community even
um and the role that you know in your
work consistently you've talked about
how you know not just political
liberalism but the advance of Science of
material technical scientific even moral
progress really depends upon an open and
free exchange of ideas
um and we seem to be in a new era where
it's not simply governments that are you
know putting the boot to things you
mentioned people like Michael
schellenberger uh we've talked about I
think Matt taibi we've uh invoked Tim
but we've seen in this you know episode
in particular the absolute collusion
between media Outlets including social
media Outlets but also news you know
more traditional news outlets talk a
little bit about what are the important
lessons that need to be drawn from our
you know the way that we talk about
things if we're going to have not simply
a free Society but one which actually
you know where people can start to
debate ideas uh when you and I talked uh
for a reason at the very start in March
of 2020 at the very start of covet and
you had said in that conversation uh
there's no Monopoly on wisdom which is
one of the reasons why we need to have
as many people participating in
discussions as possible where are we on
that and how do we how do we make that
more robust
yeah it's it's a superb question and you
put the point well and you know for me
the shocking thing of this episode has
been how useless the mainstream has been
to our investigation I by that I mean
mainstream media
which didn't want to know about this
topic mainstream science journalists
you know most of whom were completely in
the camp of
um uh being stenographers for the
scientific establishment not being
people who were prepared to do
investigative work
uh uh mainstream politicians who on the
whole didn't want to dig into this stuff
um uh the uh the the the the
intelligence Community which you know I
had conversations I I joke about this
and I'm perhaps exaggerating but I had
conversations with intelligence
officials you know who breathlessly told
me in in very secretive tones things
that I'd not only read I'd written
and you know so so the people who are
paid and and then of course mainstream
scientists as well the people who are
paid large sums of money by governments
or or by big media organizations to make
this free Society work were asleep at
the switch on this issue and the people
who broke the news who who found things
out of incredible importance were people
like the Seeker a young man in India who
uh dug into Chinese websites and found
crucial academic and medical Theses
people like Francisco Rivera a Spanish
citizen without a job sitting at home
who knows how to use databases and and
developed a brilliant technique for
discovering exactly where the Chinese
scientists had collected bat samples on
which days and from which species
um uh uh people like
um a
um a business consultant in New Zealand
a French origin who um uh has been
extraordinarily good at working out
exactly what happened in Wuhan in those
early days including how many people got
sick and and who they were and which
hospitals they went to and so on these
are informal
internet sleuths reasons called them
um I don't want to leave anyone out
drastic was the sort of umbrella name
for for a number of them they were
unpaid they were unemployed in many
cases or at least doing it in their
spare time and that's an extraordinary
part of the story that I don't want to
get lost and I I have I see a tendency
when even the lab leakers get together
and have a conference or they do a
podcast I mean to leave that aspect out
and I think that's a Pity because it
really does show how the citizen has a
role to play even in this high-tech
World
um and good for these Davids that they
went in there and fewer and threw a
stone at some goliaths hey thanks for
watching that clip from our conversation
with Matt Ridley about the origins of
the covid-19 pandemic you can watch
another clip from that conversation
right here or the full conversation
right here